son soutien pour trouver une solution et
une façons d'interpréter les documents
en négociation actuellement
merci à la partie russe à notre
partenaire à la russie de nous avoir
donné cette opportunité de participer à
cette réunion et d'avoir organisé cette
réunion le 8 janvier avec notre
partenaire russe
nous avons travaillé ensemble pour faire
une déclaration commune concernant en
cessez-le-feu
et puis nous avons travaillé sur le
document il s'agit aussi de travail sur
ce document aujourd'hui nous avons
entrer en compte les propositions faites
par le maréchal haftar et comme monsieur
labeaume l'a dit monsieur sarr hadji
mechri ont signé ce document
et nous la partie turque nous avons reçu
ce document
et comme c'est la preuve l'a dit mais ce
haftar jusqu'à demain jusqu'à demain
matin va examiner ce document est demain
matin si after signe ce document c'est à
dire que le résultat d'une initiative
proposée par les deux présidents
nous allons parvenir à une situation où
on serre à ger haftar vont prendre les
engagements nécessaires et le cessez le
feu va poursuivre le processus politique
dans le cadre des efforts de la
communauté internationale et de l'onu va
poursuivre aussi nous allons lancer le
processus politique en coopération avec
la partie russe nous avons décidé de
vous informer de cela c'était une longue
journée de longues négociations merci
votre patience et de votre travail
que vous avez fait pendant ce jour nous
voulions remercier monsieur sarr hadji
mechri qui ont signé ce document et qui
quoi le fait positif du cessez-le-feu
merci